non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
et de l'amour
le panier
le français a pris l'habitude
3 vous pouvez comprendre je suis comme
ça
cherchez pas elle comprend et douter
toute la ville en matière
je chante pour ceux qui m'aiment
je serai toujours le même
il n'y a pas de trop
je chante une fenêtre 4
donnez moi
les
l'onu
[Musique]
et
donnez moi
les jours
si la luna
[Musique]
mathieu bien vu par mathieu est à fond
mathieu on s'en rappelle qu'avec
chantait déjà duel rico bastia c'est mon
pote et ce soir ça a tenu encore une
fois à rendre hommage
ben rico qui était à ça donc je voulais
chanter ou soma jusqu'au bout ça dérange
pas tu va nous chanter des fidèles et un
fils de mon pays la france mais tu ne
pas être lancées plus la même coupable
est-ce que ça salomi comme asia sabin et
mac qui avait les cheveux plus longs
mais il a toujours été mots quelle que
soit la coupe c'est vrai qu'il est bonne
car elle rend un hommage physique et
vocal alors vas-y ossature je te l'avais
dit d'aller faire un tour à jableh
formation on peut manger quelque chose
chez laquelle tu veux aller pas que tu
vas être joué sur scène
alors il a pu donner moi j'ai fait
raquel son joli micro les gars voyez sur
le coup ah oui les mecs ça non mais un
artiste et humides sur tout le monde
hein j'avais rêvé quand paulo a non j'ai
pas vu alors vas-y à lui a dit à l'aise
comme très bon jeu du pilier de tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
leila leila boubekeur joly
c'est un homme d'affaires tistics que tu
as l'air ou bien va t excuse auprès de
dexia confondu avec un claude françois
[Applaudissements]
rien à votre talent mais vous avez tout
mon talent mais ça m'a donné des idées
de celle de me de mise en scène si vous
le voulez les 18 et 19 juin alors allo
la paye des libres voilà il serait non
pas le prendre à la fin du spectacle
non pardon ça chez enrico qui sera libre
les 18 et 19 juin et bien sûr toute la
saison